today's topic love is overrated the
concept of love is one of the most
overused amorphous useless definitions i
may have ever heard whenever i talk to
people about love i'm just like what
does that mean
and everyone's got a different
definition and what's more
they use the word in every circumstances
basically
reducing it to nothing i've come to
realize that in the west
love is just this romantic idea that
people have overused and marketed to the
point where they've killed it
they've killed it i love these shoes i
love this plate of food
i love food in general i'm such a foodie
i love sleeping i love my father i love
my children
i love you i love love but do you love
the food the same way you love your dad
no
but why don't you have a different word
it means different things based off the
context
okay interesting i want a love that's
explosive and emotion and passion
full of compassion and all these things
and i want to
and just love you and i want to feel
loved back and just oh
i know sometimes i want to crush you i
love you so much and
and i want to i want to crush you and
then reassemble you and then kiss you
and then feel you love me and sometimes
i want to make love to you
you know what i mean like to use it in
every context uh yeah i've said that
before
i know in my life that there was a
difference between my mom and my dad
my mom was always like i love you love
you love you love you love you love you
love you
love you love you okay but i love you
okay love you love you love you love you
love you
it's nice to be you don't say to hear
that your mom loves you it's really nice
but my dad he used it three times
probably
in his lifetime but one one one time
that he said it the most
and man everything that that word
meant it meant everything every
letter of it every intention when
he said listen son
i love you
that [ __ ] hit me like a truck because i
know that he uses it
when it matters the most you know i'm
not clowning my mom or whatever what not
that's the way that she does it
and it's cute when she does it but you
do diminish
the power that it has if you say it all
the time you know what i mean
same thing with certain other words in
rap songs right
as far as that you know love that word
they don't teach you what it is and they
don't
if they teach you they don't teach you
properly every grown-up that's gonna try
to say to a child
what is okay mommy what is love it's
gonna be garbage
why because your parents don't know what
the [ __ ] they're doing look just like
the rest of us okay
they we don't when you become an adult
you don't know what you're doing you're
just winging it
okay and they don't know and love
everybody got their description i have
my description
everybody got their description took me
a long time to say to my partner
i love you it took it took a long ass
long ass time
why because i didn't know i just didn't
know
the definition of it and having someone
that you don't know
i don't know you so it's not after six
months that i'm gonna be able to say
six months is not enough to know someone
in order for me to know someone
to love someone i need to know them so
i'm not after six months
gonna tell you i love you i'm not gonna
tell you after one year or two years of
going out with you
and we're in our teens and you're gonna
change and i'm gonna change
i don't know if i'm in love
or if i love you i mean i like you a lot
at that time i mean i like you a lot
but i mean i really like capri suns you
know what i mean
it's like see it's a lot of things it
took me a while to say that because you
have to know the person
you have to and it's not a six month
thing it's not even a year thing it
depends
it all depends even someone when she was
saying to me i
i love you and i was like
you don't know me you don't know what
i've been through you don't know what i
am you don't know what i have to go
through it's
hard after six months to be like i love
you finish a letter with
i love you love the idea of me that's
what i respond when fans go like
oh you all preach i love you so much
you're so great no
that's a lie you don't know me you don't
love me you love the idea
of me but until that idea
is confirmed like a donkey perm it's an
idea not actual love how do you know if
they love the idea i think they just
realize
i think we we don't have a good lexicon
to describe the range of emotions that
we
feel so we use this umbrella term for
everything
and at some points like what does this
mean i've heard you use it 20 times in
different sentences about
inanimate objects and things you watched
on television and people you know and
people you
even hate i [ __ ] love that [ __ ]
weird sentence right yeah but that's
powerful though
i don't know it depends the who and
that's the thing
maybe we need more words i mean i know i
think we do my native
people from uh northern of canada the
inuits i believe they have
27 words for snow
you know why because snow is very
important to them
the different textures the different
colors of snow means different things
so they need to have different words
to define what kind of snow because
their life depend on it
that snow's not the same snow that we're
gonna use to make your you make where
you live
that snow's not the same snow that where
the bears are
that's so 20 i think we need to go and
engage in that
with love and love i think it's greek or
whatever that they have different
words for love you know us and all that
whatever we need more words
but you know what that's never going to
happen because love is one of the best
things to use for marketing
they love to sell you stuff using the
word love
yeah it's too much money involved so
it's like don't you want to love the
toilet paper that you use
when you're wiping your dirty [ __ ]
don't you need some charmin that you
love
no and these guys i love pampers these
bears love to wipe their butt
you know it's just like we can't stop
and so it just kind of
killed the whole notion in a lot of ways
i'm not saying that the emotion that
you're feeling
in those circumstances for somebody that
you deeply care about is not real what
i'm just saying is like
the word has been used and overused so
much it's like
at some point it's like i don't know
what that means but i can understand the
intention
behind what you say when you mean in a
different way you know based off the
context but sometimes
it's like do overuse that word so like
sometimes when you say to me it's just
like what does that even mean
and there's some people that put too
much emphasis on the word itself
and they don't pay attention to other
things i'm with this guy and he never
says i love you
like we do all these things and we never
say i love you okay
all right that's my let's just no that's
my bro
i'm like okay the word love is so
important to you
right all right but there's different
way to say that you love someone
does that person pay for the bill yes
does that person cook for you
yes does that person pick you up yes did
that person ever bought you things
when you didn't expect it i'm not
talking about valentine's day i'm not
talking about your birthday i'm not even
talking about
christmas when you didn't expect it yes
then that [ __ ] loves you but
you're so
into the word love yeah that you don't
even look at the action all that is jam
you can hear
yeah but he tells me he loves me he
beats you all the time
he screams at you and when he wants to
say that he's sorry
he says i love you to make the pill pass
the word
love is just water to that pill that
he's trying to make you swallow while
he's not doing
all those actions to actually love you
he doesn't care for you
hey babes how was your day if i want to
hear about your stupid day
i love you that means i care yo what
happened with uh
you know you told me there was something
like that what what happened with that
and you you told me you was about that's
love
there's different languages of love but
people are just
throwing that word all the time and if
it's thrown at them
everything is all good i don't know
it's something that is overused but at
the same time it's really i know that it
sounds
contradictory but it's something that we
overuse and it loses is
power but there's some people that
really just need
that word that is thrown everywhere to
say like hey you know what that word was
said
so we need to reevaluate the power of
love the power
of love celine dion i'm out
check the patreon tell us what you think
don't forget to subscribe
subscribe god dammit
foreign